Well, it's really the same stupid
logic where I was talking about were,
you know Gavin was saying punch people.
When you punch people,
it doesn't end there. Oh, my band
band them. It doesn't end there.
It doesn't end there. You give to
realize also a Twitter is how old now?
11 years old. 12 years old. 13 years old.
13 years old. Well, 13 years from now.
What are the odds that there's not going
to be something else? Just like it? Well,
pretty slim. Uh, how we do
a million, no, but let's,
let's talk about the
incestuous relationship that
a lot of these journalists
have been defending the policies you
guys push. Gab It was, was, was a,
a study was done.
I talked about this last time where they
found 5% of the tweet of the say tweets,
but the posts on Gab where hate speech
compared to Twitter's like 2.4 so it's a
marginal increase yet gab is
called the white supremacy network.
Of course you go on it and yeah,
absolutely exists.
They say that synagogue shooter. Oh, he
was a gap user. He was a Twitter user too.
He posted on Twitter all the time. So
why the media is, is targeting, it's,
it's such a crazy nightmarish reality.
It is active narrative.
And when the Guardian,
uh,
I believe it was the Daily Mail called
Count Danky Law Nazi hate criminal.
It's not really made a joke on youtube
and he's being, he was arrested. Um,
I thank God every day we have the
first amendment in this country.
Well there was a cover of a newspaper
that was cause he got a new job somewhere
they get, he got fired for that. He got
kicked off the show. Wow. Yeah. That's so,
so you have cause of trying again. It,
let me ask you another thing. Do you guys,
do you guys take the advice of
the southern poverty law center?
Did we take the advice of like, so it's,
it's widely circulated. The SPLC lobbies,
various social platforms to ban
certain people. They advise. Uh,
it's an important advised youtube as,
as the Anti Defamation League.
Do you use them in your decision
making process? It rule development.
We're very aware of the flaws with
certain of their research and we're very
careful about who we take advice from.
But do you take advice from them?
I think that they have certainly
reached out to our team members,
but they are certainly nothing
definitive that we take from them.
We don't take action.
You'll never take an action based on
the information received from them.
The reason I bring them up specifically
is that they're cited often, you know,
in the United States,
there's other groups like a hope not hate
in the UK and now they're all going to
point their, you know, figurative
guns at me for saying this.
But the southern poverty law center,
uh,
wrote an article where they claimed I
went to Iran for a Holocaust deniers
conference and I've never been to a round.
And their evidence was this guy found
an archived website from a Holocaust
denier with my name on it.
And that was their proof.
And there are people who
have been labeled, you know,
extremists by this organization
that have been Sam Harris.
Sam Harris was started, was, I mean
it, didn't, they lose a big lawsuit.
They settled. Yeah. So, so again, like
not, not to imply that you guys do use it,
but I asked specifically because it's
been reported to other organizations do.
So we have activist organizations,
we have journalists that
I can attest to our APP,
absolutely activists because I've
worked for, I worked for vice,
I worked for a fusion. I was told, uh,
it implicitly not explicitly to lie to
side with the audience as, as it were.
I've seen the narratives they push and
I've had conversations with people that
I'm not going to, I'm going to
keep relatively off the record.
Journalists who are terrified because
they said the narrative is real. Right.
One journalists in particular said that
he had, he had evidence of, you know,
essentially he had reason to
believe there was a wrongdoing,
but if he talks about it, he
could lose his job. And there,
there was a journalist who reported to
me that data in society admitted their
report was, was, was,
was, was, uh, incorrect.
And now you've got organizations lobbying
for terminating Joe and I because of
this stuff. So this,
this narrative persists.
Then you see it all the actions I
mentioned before and all the organizations
saying we're doing the right thing. And I
got to say like we're living in, I mean,
I feel like we're looking at the doorway
to the nightmare dystopia of, yeah, I, I,
I just want to clarify like, uh, I don't,
I don't know if we're going
around and saying we're,
we're necessarily doing the right thing.
We're saying why we're doing
what we're doing. Right? Right.
That's what we need to get better at.
And I don't want to hide behind
what we believe is like the,
the right thing.
We have to clearly rationalize why we're
making the decision we're making and
more of that.
That's,
that to me is the prevention from
snowflake avalanche metaphor. Well, but,
but I think it's just obvious to
point out, again, I said this before,
we can have the calm conversation
and I can understand you,
but for where I'm from,
where I'm sitting,
you hold a vastly different ideology
than I do and you have substantially more
power and controlling my government.
That terrifies me. And what's,
what makes it worse is that
a Saudi prince, uh, as,
as it was reported that Saudi prince
owns a portion of that company.
So I'm sitting here like, just a little
American, can't do anything to stop it.
I'm just watching this unaccountable
machine churn away and you're just one
snowflake in an avalanche. All these
other companies are as well. And I'm like,
well, here we go. This
is going to be a ride.
That's if it just said that Saudi
princes doesn't have any influence,
but am I supposed to trust that that's
the, that's the issue, right? I'm not,
I'm not trying to insinuate he's shown
up to your meetings and telling you what
to do, but when someone dumps $1 billion
a year company, I think it's silly to,
to imply that they don't at least have
some influence, but, but regardless,
and unlike the Internet
within a company like ours,
you don't necessarily see the protocol.
You don't see the, the processes. And,
and that's just an area where we can
do a lot much later, I guess, you know,
beat it over the head a
million times. It'd be the dead
horse. I think ultimately,
yeah, I get what you're
doing. I think it's wrong.
I think it's terrifying and I
think we're looking, we're slow,
we're on the avalanche
already has happened and where
we're heading down to this
nightmare scenario of the future where
it terrifies me when I see people who
claim to be supporting liberal ideology,
burning signs that say free speech,
threatening violence against other people.
You have these journalists
who do the same thing.
They accuse everybody of being a Nazi,
everybody of being a fascist Joe Rogan
and you're like, you're like a socialist.
As far as I know, you're
like ubi proponent. You know,
I wouldn't necessarily say much
so I'm very, I'm being facetious.
I'm because of liberal
except for second amendment.
That's probably the only thing that
I disagree with a lot of liberals.
And then you see what the media says about
everybody and you see how they called
Jordan Peterson all day and night.
Alt Right, alt right hates him. And,
and this narrative is used to strip
people of their income to remove them from
public discourse.
And it's foolish because it ultimately,
upon examination,
like you were saying, that sunlight
is the best disinfection. Absolutely.
Upon examination,
you realize that this is not true at all,
and that these people look foolish. Like
the date in society, uh, article, no, no.
Know all these organizations published
that as fact without looking at any data.
Maybe some did, but anybody, but
yeah, man, no, no, no, no, no.
They still tiding up millions
and millions of people who's,
who are these people that are
still siding it? Guardian. Well,
clients start yelling shame,
but so, so, so look foolish.